[Music]
he's also a lot of money having it's
very strong program in information
thanks to Seth
now that the nomina Popkin described the
big picture and I would like to
exemplifies some of their comments
statements by describing specific
research programs who have been
conducting as a matter of fact quite
exciting things are happening in the
double of laboratory and I like to do my
best to convince you in a how the
information on technology including
assumin tations and the networking staff
can change both exploring the new
frontiers and some of the revitalized
the area that which has been already
mature in the mainstream mechanical
engineer now first of all I'd like to
raise this instrumentation and
networking issue is a quite important a
part of the information next speaker
Susana sue who is the I guess the start
the internet bro Tina this kind of
concept of networking and we learned a
lot from him we are putting lots of
little gadget in diverse state years and
we developed the little
computers that has the widest you know
transmission systems see at around
almost every press that you can imagine
including the human body getting the
good access to any machines including
robot and some other staffs but imagine
that you are sort of either augmented by
the ability to communicate with other
machine what can we do with it or are we
you can get the you know your vital
signs at all times getting a huge amount
to information we totally change the way
we do design in these areas now this
little gadget that we call this I coin
technologies because you know we have a
lot all the microcontroller izing having
so many computers and RF transmitters
combined with some batteries all in a
small package as small as their time or
order nickels and actually these are
communicating wirelessly with the some
computers now things are going to mobile
computing and these the PDAs combined
with this little wand it's going to be a
one a gadget
sometime soon and they are replacing I
brought in just brought newer laptops
but this is gonna be all the technology
it's gonna be required to buy those
things so we made a connection all these
and instead of using the different the
devices here under there but we use the
unified you know systems so that we can
actually do a lot of computations and
communications and not much but this is
the first you know device we put
together we have RF transmitters the
candid transmit the signals up to 3100
the feet and quite stable now one of the
very interesting program is with all
designed this for low e low energy
computational communications dr. erosion
mentions that the computers Peter ever
increasing but the same time what it's
interesting to me is that the power
required for each gate switch has been
decreasing as quickly as the speed of
the computers increased so math matter
fact acquire a peak you know a number of
gates can be powered by
single battery that lasts o for the
entire lifespan of data chip so it's
going to be a disposable but better
store the bottleneck is the RF
transmission and well there are quite a
few were researcher programs going on in
this area in a mobile computing
community where we look at this issue at
the very fundamental purpose of coding
and modulation which is very much you
know fundamental part so what we what we
like to do is that you like to transmit
to some signals say message em you want
to mq and you have to code it
you had represent the information some
form and you have you know collections
of such coding here and what I'd like to
do is actually well any in ascending
reaching for me
each symbol to here you have to spend
some energy say e I in well what we'd
like to do is to minimize the average
energy per transmitting message now
obviously what you can do is that well
you you can actually evaluate these
calls in terms of the energy expenditure
and put them in the increasing order of
energy consumption and assuming that you
know the source of symbol probability
you can put them in the in the
descending order of probability and you
make a match between these two and a way
to minimize this point is simply you
assign the code words with less energy
to more probable messages but this is
just another thing you know special it's
just you know extensions of Huffman
coding which is very well known so stuff
but it's very important exciting things
are happening in this code book part
which is a collection of codes now any
communication community is and I think
it's going higher bit and longer a bit
and higher transmissions and the rate
has been the most important in factors
or for many years but looking at the
those applications are just a showed you
near first the view graphs
many things that can be transmitted the
rather slowly rather slowly but a
battery power is more important
I can tell you a hundred you know
examples of that now given that we can
actually design a special code that is
optimal in terms of the energy savings
now if you just use the standard you
know coding technique so let me take
this a simple the on-off keying it to
begin with you need to send certain a
bit length so let's call the word rings
and which it has the kind of mixture to
high bit and row bit and a quite a few
things are happening now looking at the
simple the transmission form of keying
the register is consumed only when the
electric meter is on then not actually
active and things so obviously what you
need to do is to reduce number of high
bits then you can actually minimize the
energy consumption now that the suppose
you can speak a little slowly you have
as you can put some redundant bits in
here you can actually generate the cause
which which do not need many high bits
it turns out there is just a few high
high bit shown here can represent the
many many and codes this is a code
redundancy of energy saving and a we
explored how much we can actually gain
the energy saving by adding some
redundancy to it now the set of book
calls having the least the number of
hybrids
it's called optimal code book that way
you can generate it studying which the
whole orbit and then one bit and how one
drinks is used and then actually two
bits you can put and then actually you
count this one until you arrive the
point where the you do the same number
by a code words that you want to ship
out the number of also symbols then you
can corrupt and they do not use the old
other code patterns are having higher
bits but this is a simple one of course
the you know in a practice they have
been using a much more sophisticated
conservation techniques the one that I
talked about it only this one what are
many many things and happening eighties
nineties but no matter what new one
testing a property that we found is that
b2 to be able to ascend a staff in the
way the minimum energy the necessary
condition for it is that codebook that
correction of book codes must be an
optimal code book having the dismembered
of energy in it
now that the so although the
probabilities of the source symbols may
vary depending on applications but on
the code the book part that can be fixed
and we can implement this and I know I
can we have or such you know optimal
code works which is attuned to its basic
probability distributions involved in
the systems and after that we just
designed the of the mob an assignment in
between now taking one step further
a few step further from this point we we
means me and it says process asteroid
and you know hunter together are
marching towards the much more
challenging device which is called I
grain this is the complete
self-contained a computer with batteries
in it and the wireless communication a
device in it and that is as Roger as the
grain of rice and we do I integrated the
computation the communications and one
chip perceive be in a wireless
transmission which is not a easy job to
be signal stuff and the more important
thing we do integrate chip design a
battery design and are not and actually
explore the many opportunities to
clibbery why do we use the button design
in consistent towards the achieve design
and hopefully we can last
such a device for five years and turned
out to be disposable now having such a
new device we can put this one in
unusual places in particular and a human
body and we are but actually we have
been working on this one in our several
years try to put the devices on the
human
non-intrusive and a comfortable way and
then I say that actually a laptop
computer will be replaced by PDA to some
wobble gears connected to internet so
what if we can make a connection between
this one and the many are part of the
body and that we can hooked a lot of
interesting stuff and we call this a
wireless body local area network imagine
that you have such ability now we have a
quite a few were interesting
applications of that for human-computer
interactions and most specifically
recently personal robotics the booming
and a key issue the personal robotics is
basically how you let the your robot
recognize what you're really doing so
actually human measurement or a human
side of instrumentation plays a major
role and as a matter of fact you know on
this case we are by the students of
Steve Mascaro working together with this
robot and building something like this
and this robot is clever enough to
understand what he is doing and by keep
tracking up in his a hand motion there's
a matter of fact him most of the job
performed by humans are by means of the
hand motion so if you actually keep
track of the hand motion so we can get
the most of the information they need it
and I'm not Emma just to talk to one
this one specific technology with the
Bob and that is to replace the data
glove and the posture you know that this
is kind of existing technologies and we
can measure the data on the hand motion
we can measure the a bending angles and
touch them for us and such but once you
wear that lab you get the law you get
the last be a haptic sense now what you
are doing is to measure the hand motion
including it is actually you know force
acting at the attempt with that covering
the hands how can we do that but
traditional mechanical engineers you
know if you try to measure some force at
that hearing a tip you place a some you
know sensor parity here faster we're
clever enough to make it make things
very thin but though we do is a half the
extent so what is the solution
now if we have pyro fingers and then at
the tables in front of you please place
your fingers on top of the table surface
and you look at your fingernail what's
gonna happen yeah please do it you know
and you find the something good idea
that your nails change its color and
that's a very clear change so we
instrumented the fingernails and we're
still just a standard of micro LEDs in
the photo detectors and a wirelessly
communicating at s1 to other part this
is the device with the book and this is
just like a teenager and fake nails and
we can actually measure the all the
stuff now we have a very interesting a
color change and as described here now
what it's a really interesting to me is
that what we can even measure the
bending angle not only the force acting
on it but we can measure the force
actually they depending angles on top of
it this is actually a quick video clip
and I'll show you now how this one is
really working let me just skip this
first a few portion okay
now whoops
this is brand new Windows 2000 and it
may well let me just hold up this guy
deposit this one is good enough well
it's a kind of a technology vulnerable
can you see this yeah this is the you
know first part of the video and
basically we measure the veining angles
and just to get their difference we just
put some on sign here so here is
basically the tip of the finger and we
instrumented with it and we've been it
in an actually adore this one is to show
the bending angle measured by the
there's a fingernail sensor and a
nothing in the air it's not covered at
all but I bend this one we can measure
this and the top one is to indicate the
actual bending angle as a matter of fact
that this is to get to some reference so
making comparison or day
and the actual actual measurement taken
by this and actually this is a touching
part if you touch some surface the there
is sensor output the changes so you can
get the you know information as to how
much it's there being touched and this
one turns out to be working very quickly
we can't get the a measurement over you
know pianist emotion but it's who could
quite a quick amazingly quick now let me
just move on and do next one
yeah this is the last part it's actually
moving and tapping a quickly in it you
know it's actually follows that one okay
now moving forth as a matter of fact the
the finger nail bed and has quite
interesting characteristics although
it's not much known we have quite two
rich capillary system to right the penis
this one a capillary tube is the twice
longer than the other part so many
little the Fossum and asked actually
changes the color now we a mechanic
engineering and trying to understand why
that's a happen the sole this is the
kind of a fluid the mechanics and the
tissue mechanics apart and then we try
to design build some model how it really
works and then a check it in with the
actual experiments now we're moving
towards the wireless sensor die having
that the I coin communicating were see
any budget the gadget and one more
interesting stuff with this is that the
we cannot judge measured shear force
well shear forces Zener is very
difficult to measure but with this we
can actually see the very distinct you
know car apart and change so we can
imagine that now what is the killer app
of this then we are actually applying
this to repress the computer pointer if
you use the IBM a laptop you see a
little in red stuff in the middle of the
keypad and that's sometimes very
difficult to move but with this one you
can just use any surface and and the
point of what you really want to
actually look at and open the file well
of course you know this I wanna see you
instrument the human there are many ways
of gaining information from the human
such as in this case in this case the
traditionally some switches embedded in
the wall but with this new sensor you
don't have to do that you can just pose
paste the picture of this switch and
that once you touch this guide and then
you get the information of course we
need to have
some additional sensors to locate the
fingers went in our case we're using the
mounting magnetic tracker but that can
be done and in this case the robot is
actually controlled where the many as
basically switch is embedded on this
table now this the type of virtual
switch enhance the human-machine
communications for instance in this case
it's a traditional switches and then
many people get the trouble to
understand which what this is which
means in the resulting the certain
action here making connections a very
difficult to task but the virtual switch
we place the switch each word tasks take
place so it's very easy to understand no
man now let me just talk about a little
bit more mechanical oriented the work
and how they are connected to what
information stuffs now this is actually
the care project that we're doing and
this is the stuff you see in the daily
lives a patient here has been struggling
moving from transferring from this in a
wheelchair to bed and but bit chewy
words here and first we devolve the kind
of a hybrid better chair systems this
one I can be prude out in a bed and they
move around freely it's around
additional tiers we've been working this
one with VA hospitals and what they
experience is that they're having a
manís with many actuators that are a
little difficult to operate but we place
the virtual switches on all these places
and the first way look at how those
caregivers tends to touch to move for
instance raising this back and we place
the virtual switch there of course the
virtual switches are sometimes on the
fabrics like this one where the demurrer
you can to put the traditional switches
but we can play such an stuff now
along these directions let me describe
to you one very challenging a project in
this quarter surface wave actuation and
the goal is to move the a bedridden
patient in two directions and x and y
direction
without lifting so the surface must they
have some kind of functionality so that
the patient can be moved in any
directions and in this case we embed
some kind of actuators in here and the
surface will generate the sort of motion
in this case it's going along this kinda
circular trajectory just like on a water
surface weight and having some phase lag
you create this kind of a terrain and on
our body as I touched you at this point
worse the transition or bra stays in
this direction now well natural waves
you know it's not so much an efficient
and very difficult to realize
mechanically when instead that we made
some changes to it and that is to put to
some kind of little notch in here on the
membrane we call this extender and in
place the object on top of it what is
interesting here is that we since we
have this device when this actually
moved in out of phase they just move
this kind of action rotate about this so
create the additional velocity at the
tip of this arm and of course no one
wants to say lying on the bed of nails
like this so we put the additional
membrane on top of it and the pressure
is it creating a very softer surface
when it patient relying on it sleeping
for a long time in case we need to move
the patient to give some austerity or
change the posture we actually
depressurized this chamber and then
actually these extenders comes out and I
have a second video which is interesting
that the religious right now this whoops
have a different
we'll see let's go this is Microsoft so
we can't blame ya right now dead but
this one excuse me this guy oops
well we have a bunch of little fingers
in here they are moving a certain way
and what you see here the jell-o's it's
a very fragile object of being
transported actually bedridden patients
have a very fragile skin so amazingly
this can be transported in a very gently
it's actually moving and we can move in
any directions and interestingly the
beneath this a particular mat oh this is
actually 50 pounds at all the we can the
transport in this one in this way each
elements of this one is just moving up
up and down motions just one direction
of motion but we have a bedroll
Barchetta to finish this now
close it and
okay well the currently decides it's
just in transporting a little baby like
this but nah but how can we extend it to
a size of a full-size of bed and well
first of all we need introduce at this
point the brand new world actuator
technologies because to make her such
you know our many little emotions on the
bed we know this upper part you know
it's working very well and now we
working on the nail of such an actuator
now the one day technology we're using
is basically putting in the I coin in
here by the way Ikon has P Double M
generators in it and it has the ability
to control this once you put there
simple or built-in power stage so these
are sort of point of smart motors
everything is there and basically we can
eliminate the heavy wiring while we try
to eliminate all the wires here and
actually bending at this one on the
power bus line and we superimpose the
signals on here so that these devices
can be coordinated in a certain way well
of course
well more important application may be
automobiles or some other places where
there's so many so many motors are being
used but in an as matter of fact they
have during the heavy harness cables
after K was a real didn't very difficult
jobs so if we can actually put them
together and putting everything in one
cable I mean 12 volts power lines
nothing else that pays off well actually
working on this kind of a work we I
found that the more even a traditional
mechatronics system design putting the
communications and networking stuff in
the re stage of a system design turns
out to be very important dealing with
the such complex systems are having many
many actuators and not just a
traditional of the approach is too
costly so that we should above the other
technologies in doing so now let me just
move on to wearable were here supporting
system to its
a major part of the project the back
nine is sex we propose this kind of
systems having a ring sensor monitoring
the vital signs of these patients and
putting this one the data into someplace
someone watching this or all the times
now we got the patent on this ring
sensors basically monitoring the house
and the saturated oxygen level and every
year we develop the new ones were just
now very reliable also in that course
you know we succeeded in the measuring
the blood the pressure without using a
cuff this is a traditional method of
measuring the historic and s district
pressures but we instead use the very
different technologies we're using a
sort of a sensor fusion and techniques
and the common filtering to get the
blood pressure by a combination of
little sensors in this case the tooling
sensors prosody electrical impedance
precision graph can reconstruct the
blood pressure when these three
measurements are done at the same time
and we did some benchmarking which the
FDA approved manometer and our common
filter sensor fusion techniques can
create ste as good that they wave form
as the those if they approve the devices
what is actually not just a high
pressure and low pressure but it will
complete the waveform that can be
estimated which I provides a very rich
variety of information such as the
cardiac contraction strengths and
peripheral vascular resistance
information now how does job in putting
this in certain humans basically the
motion artifact in this ring sensor the
case we have to gently hold the device
so that the we do not interfere the
blood circulation in here now it took us
some time to solve this program and we
came up with this doubling constructions
having over heavy stuff and outer rings
and inner rings are hosting only the
sensor unit
which is extremely lightweight and so
even though you move the hands the
inertial force created on this it's
offical anyway and M is so small that
via the force acting on it is very much
in English ball there's the kind of
axiomatic in approach we basically
decouple the functionality and we solve
the lots of your programs
so in case you actually touch the same
Sun something because no one is actually
administrating at this kind of
measurement so the patient just moved
this one and doing some daily jobs so
what may touch into some other place but
I know the force acting on it is
basically shielded by this and after
affecting the internal force what we did
somehow finite element analysis is again
a mechanic engine program and then
actually there have the precise model of
the tissue mechanics has to do and how
these are really measured and how we can
improve the air performance we did a
benchmarking with the EKG in PPG
fda-approved devices and then this ring
sensors has no significant difference in
terms of pulse compared with the EKG and
other FDA approved photo presses mograph
even though we move this one what touch
this one we get the consistent two data
and everything is designed for low power
consumption
it will continue 360 days now what is
the missing link we have devoted quite a
few things but so it takes some time to
get the used in a real medical community
missing names is basically the lack of a
protocol how it should be measured and
how it should be monitored and how data
should be used what this continues motor
angles you know concept is new and then
actually there's no such you know really
useful devices and gadgets have been
available the upon asking the doctors
they don't have a clear idea how to yuri
really use it the many of them really
like it but i know comes down to the
specific questions about the protocol it
is a different story
now the the new device with the icon and
as the bi-directional communication
abilities so actually we are planning at
this kind of here to test exploiting the
IT well here's the device on the queue
on the patient side and it's collected
to be primary behind it's a PDA and a
signal on that to Anna website and
actually this one is moister divine
doctor's office we are deploying about a
100 the ring sensors at the various
locations and we really like to see how
the doctor use this one as a matter of
fact we provide the large selections
option to all the different measurements
or protocols and that doctors make a
decisions as to which one to be taken
and that may require the some change on
this ring side half the program to need
to be changed but that program can be
downloaded from the website too so that
then although we have the hundreds of
icons and the field but we can remotely
change programs and in the change the
way we basically are correct the data
and one would like to do is that they
might ease double flap we we actually
monitor tap the all the informations
send between the patient side and the
doctor's office to see how the doctors
are using this and exploiting new ways
of monitoring those cardiovascular
activities in a continuous manner but so
reflecting there is a Everton's easy and
now the vast information they're coming
out but the prominence that physical
systems are highly coupled and well not
your assistant the base card in highly
couples ortho for design we should be
able to decouple it but unfortunately
many physical systems are coupled to for
instance cardiovascular systems brusha
brusha brusha changes depending original
state or respiration state and many
things are made may change now no single
doctor can cover all these an idiot so
we try to find some ways of developing
technology to
put all the piece of knowledge together
in particular each system has a
simulator and in each and expert to
devote in the course these simulation
programs and if we have some ways of
running old DSO together by exchanging
parameter and available so together we
can study the cup of the behavior of
such assistance and this is a quote Co
simulation environment and I don't want
to go to a details but I know well
besides the very much computer and
software programs the hardest part of
the problem is really the dynamics and
dynamics and in the part of the probe
know you have to sub simulators coded
the separatory but you try to put
together to solve the cup of the problem
these estate Avada was not no more
independent have to conform to some
boundary conditions and you can't reduce
these eliminate these variables in case
they are all the nonlinear so what you
need to do is basically code use the
existing codes and they run it together
well you know it happening for instance
actually this is the building energy
systems and many bandits bringing the
different part of devices in this case
and some evaporator or heat exchangers
they have a pretty good knowledge about
these and they have some simulators in
here but I not try to put them together
to see how these work together
for instance the mass flow rate must be
consistent and the pressure of these
three points must be the same which
actually poses the sort of algebraic
constraints it turns out the system
becomes an algebraic differential
algebraic equations and we if we have
some ways of solving this kind of
problem effectively that actually makes
things a much easier and we solve this
by using the control theory standpoint
seeing this kind of differential
equations as a feedback process treating
this output this algebraic constraint
which is to be driven 0 and
is treated as output function and close
the feedback loop so that this output is
to be driven to zero and we designed
this feedback control very rigorously by
using control theory such as writing
about the controls and such this is to
give to precisely the error bound and
stability conditions rather than just
doing the trying there are jobs of
course these things are very important
nowadays and people are talking about
e-commerce and you have they have big
supreme change systems and the automaker
has to make a decision as to which
components are usable in these systems
and they do largely by using the
simulators they are no longer using the
data chart and stuff but they use
simulators and overnight they have to
make a quick decisions and what you need
to do is actually getting a simulators
around here you must be able to Co
around those simulators with the main
part of your product such as the main
body or engine control systems and you
have to make a quick decisions and then
you can to change the code originally
you had to run it all together so the
way I see it in a I Tina it's a it's a
it's a nice catalysis for integrating
and we dis prints what tradition in our
department we've been using energy as
interdisciplinary quantity to describe
the all these fields in a unified way
now I think when my point of view
informations is now playing the same
similar law and extending that
information is the most fundamental the
common factor that actually integrate
all these stuffs and I think that is the
kind of a direction where we are looking
at not just acknowledge that Tia this
most of the job has been done under the
sponsorship of a motivating health care
consortium and three grant from National
Science Foundation's and I acknowledge
many of my colleagues in the table who
brought me a very different type of
expertise and
from them thank you very much well an
interesting topic is wood now running
quite behind schedule is a will defer
questions ask questions you can break
your lunch
our next speaker is a sunny suit those
are you know nam soon note that he can
be quite persuasive he persuaded me to
lead physics enjoyed the mechanical
engineering department so these two was
already well established professor of
electrical engineering when Tom exerted
his persuasive powers on sunny
unlike Al Gore something she did not
invent the Internet
however unlike Al Gore he did and then
he did invent a key part of what is
going to become the next generation of
ATM or asynchronous transfer mode so
becoming internet over the next 10 years
so why don't you discuss today I have to
apologize because I have a very serious
flu for the past couple of days it's
about the next generation Internet
acknowledges I guess it's not
exaggerating to say that the reasoned
information revolution has to do a lot
with the Internet and of course I guess
a lot of the the boom market in the
stock market it's a lot to do with the
Internet - so and I'm also teaching a
undergraduate course I guess would be it
is the first cause over by MIT at the
very freshman sex off more level on the
Internet
and I used like - when when I teach
class I usually like to tell the
students there are really three key
elements of the Internet
first is the applications under the the
well-known World Wide Web actually
spawns the widespread use of the
Internet and sooner or later we can
actually talk over the Internet
first currently you can actually get
some software which allow you to have
free long distance call but the quality
is still not very good when in the
future the quality will get better and
better and very soon will have actually
free long distance call flat-rate long
distance call nationally or even
internationally okay and in the very
near future we will see a lot more other
applications of the internet for example
networking physical objects okay using
the internet and professor sama will be
talking about it will be careful and
talk in the afternoon and in the use of
the Internet to network physical objects
that is a very recent project that we
have started at MIT funded by a number
of industrial companies ok and we have a
lot of application or impact on
manufacturing the inventory control as
well as supply chain management ok
another key come
of the internet is network protocols I
guess most of you use the worldwide web
and then use the Netscape Browser
Internet Explorer to browse the web and
the HTTP protocol that you use actually
once on top of TCP IP and many other
data applications use tcp/ip and then at
the lower layer is the link and physical
layer technologies including your cable
modem technology a DSL for the broadband
access as well as the the older
technology is called asynchronous
transfer mode that self I mentioned
before also we are seeing the WDM
optical technologies coming up and being
used in the access area too so let me go
into a bit more detail describing all
these different technologies ok and
before that I just want to tell you
about some key challenges ok that we
face in developing the next generation
Internet ok first of all the Internet is
about scalability ok and in the very
near future we will see the internet
being used to connect maybe billions of
computers and embedded processors ok and
again in the future we'll see that the
Internet is going to be used to connect
physical objects ok and that might be
linked to even trillions ok of every
piece of physical item that you can
imagine
ok and the second challenges in the
efficiency currently we use fiber optics
ok they can provide a lot of raw
bandwidth ok the challenging issue is
how you can turn all this raw capacity
to usable bandwidth ok meaning that you
can provide end-to-end user to user
performance in the range of gigabit or
even terabit per second ok
currently a terribie per second is
already available in backbone
technologies linking very big backbone
routers but most user could not even get
multi megabit per second to the desktop
ok and the third issue is about quality
of service ok what that means is current
internet is based on the best
for service paradigm in the sense that
when you try to visit a website for
example sometimes you really have to
wait for seconds if not minutes because
you have no control of the current
congestion status in the network and if
we talk about futuristic applications
like Terry robotics okay Terry tele
surgery you require really very tight
control of the bandwidth as well as the
delay okay so that's what we mean by the
quality of service and today's internet
doesn't have that okay and of course in
the very near future we see the
convergence of cellular phones and
Internet devices together and currently
a if you buy a cell phone like this from
Sprint PCS it offer you about only 10
kilobits per second because the existing
cellular technologies are optimized for
voice communications okay but not for
browsing the web or downloading a big
files okay and the goal in the next
generation and that project I have
involved with is to really increase the
rate to thousand times more okay to
multi megabit per second range the the
last but not the least challenging issue
is interoperability okay the
telecommunication carriers has invested
billions of dollars in the existing
infrastructure it would be impossible
for them to tell them to really abandon
all these existing infrastructure and
then go for the new technologies so
whatever new technology we come up with
we better make sure inspect what
compatible with the existing
infrastructure and that's another
challenge it's a matter of fact when you
think about TCP and IP they're actually
legacy protocols but they work very well
in the past 30 years so the idea is how
you can improve those protocols to work
on different platforms and heterogeneous
technologies all right so let me just
talk about one of the very exciting new
technology called optical network
technology called wavelength division
multiplexing okay this is a research
project that I have been in
off with with Lincoln laboratory at MIT
and the number of other companies
involving AT&T Nortel GDS Yuna face
these technologies is optical technology
that enables a very cost-effective
therapy per second bandwidth in backbone
optical networks and the ongoing
research that we have in this next
generation internet project funded by
DARPA okay that's about a 16 million
dollar project that we have at MIT that
goes on for another year or so is to
develop very efficient WDM architectures
and protocols to support therapy per
second even in the access area access
area means the last mile that connects
your corporate router to the central
office in a local carrier okay
again you have a loss of bandwidth in
the backbone but very limited bandwidth
in the access area and our goal is try
to really increase the bandwidth in
depth even in the excess area alright so
let me explain a little bit about how
this technology works without going too
much detail okay to just oversimplify a
little bit
the technology allows you to divide the
spectrum okay of in a in a optical fiber
into multiple channels so that in
current technology you can actually
divide the optical spectrum into maybe
100 channels now it was each channel
running at about to KKP per second so
immediately you can already have to get
200 gigabit per second in the fiber
easily okay in the future may go up to a
few hundred channels and which each
channel going at ten gigabit per second
so then you can have multi therapy per
second okay so the the reason why this
is such an attractive technology is that
it offers you very low cost okay because
many of the components you use are
passive components okay again to
oversimplify you can think of them as
just mirrors and prisms okay so it can
bypass the electronic bottleneck
currently of course optical fiber is
used to connect electronic switches but
every time your signals has to be
converted from optical signal to
electric
No and then get processed by this
routers so we're heating already the
electronic performance bottleneck but by
replacing those electronic switches by
optical components such as mirrors and
prisms okay you don't have the
electronics performance bottleneck so
you can be switched at much faster rate
at terabit per second all right the
challenge is how we can actually scale
again these kind of technologies so that
millions or even hundreds of millions of
users can exit them access them at a
very low cost and how we interoperate
with the existing billions of info
billions of dollars of electronic
infrastructure okay they have been
invested by the carriers all right
and how all these existing tcp/ip
protocol works over these optical
technologies all right and this is a WDM
based architecture that we have designed
in this next generation internet
projects from the by DARPA the above at
the in the above left hand corner is the
is the backbone Network okay for example
of this and this part is usually refer
as the access area okay access area
could be it for example Boston
metropolitan area okay and each of these
node is called the excess node and
usually is connected to in the rain
fashion and that's usually referred to
the feeder network this ring could be
about 50 kilometer in diameter all right
and after the after connected to all
this excellent snow what we call the
distribution networks and they could be
arranged in a tree-like fashion or a
ring life fashion in each of these
little dot okay an example of like could
be for example MIT campus router or a
Harvard okay and the idea is we want to
provide therapy per second okay even in
the access area okay currently I guess
most of you use the local area network
which is about 10 megabit per second
okay
and what we want to do is provide very
high bandwidth to the desktop so that
you can really receive all kinds of
signals to a tower video on you know
text on and that's also a trend in the
convergence of the television
the PC okay that you can actually get
all sorts of information video video
on-demand everything is a very low cost
using a single infrastructure rod and
you're receiving it your voice from
telephone network and your broadcast TV
signals from another cable
infrastructure again this is regarding
lowering cost okay so I already
mentioned that the in the distribution
area the reason why optical technology
is so attractive is is passive okay it
doesn't require power okay the power is
really needed only at the end station as
well as to the central office one of the
challenges that internet traffic
unlike voice is very bursty when you
download when you browse the web most of
the time you're idling after you
download the webpage okay so it's very
bursty in nature and it's very hard to
predict the traffic and that causes a
lot of challenging issues in using
optical technologies because optical
technologies are circuit switching okay
in general that means you establish
light paths okay between end-users and
my research focuses on how we can share
those wavelengths or channels very
effectively okay in the sense that if
you have 64 wavelengths or channels and
to be shared by let's say 2000 buildings
how you can share them in a very
efficient manner under the assumption
that the Internet traffic is very bursty
okay so this is a very challenging issue
and that we have been looking at the
idea is we want to really currently that
your cable modem at home if you use
cable modem over here about a megabit
per second okay
what we try to build in this project
okay in the optical project is the to
build another modem but we call the
optical modem they can offer you a
gigabit per second
okay so a thousand times faster modem
okay that can be connected to your PC
okay now let me switch here okay that's
another major area of my research used
on the wireless area okay so before we
talk about a wide line technology okay
using optical fiber WDM technology and
another major area
report my research is in the next
generation wireless technologies and
this is a joint project with four entity
DoCoMo for those of you who don't know
untidy DoCoMo it is demo the major
mobile operator in Japan okay it's a
spinoff from the parent company entity
but now is a much larger company than
the parent company entity it is about
the is the fourth largest company in the
world in terms of market cap okay so
they and they are really very advanced
in wireless technology a major player
behind it's not a standardization of the
third generation system okay I would
like to give you some maybe the
historical overview of how the wireless
system evolved okay in the late 80s or
mid 80s we have the analog system that
we refer to this first generation system
actually if you are a subscriber to
cellular the one some of the phones are
still based on analog okay again because
there's already a lot of money invested
in those analog infrastructure and right
now you can get very low cost if you use
analog technology and in the early in
the early 90s we saw the the digital
second generation system which is based
on digital technology and thus for
example GSM and the CDMA technology used
in the USA and they offered you about 10
kilobits per second okay the reason why
we only need such a low bandwidth in
these system is that most of the
communications or the traffic you often
leave voice ok and voice is a very
predictable is a kind of very
predictable bandwidth traffic okay and
compressed voice only requires about 10
kilobits per second okay and in the
emerging third generation system it is
based on what we call the wideband CDMA
technology the standard is called
imt-2000 and in third generation
technology that will be rolled out in
Japan next year in the u.s. is probably
will take another two years before we
see this technology it has promised to
offer you about a 300 to 400 kilo pay
per second for mobile user
you're driving in the car this is
probably what you'll get about 300
kilobits per second and that will allows
you to have pretty good bandwidth in
order to browse the web the reason why
we they came up with this number 3G
kilobit per second is that a typical web
page with some graphics in it actually
is about 300 kilobit okay so and they
calculate that a human's response the
tolerance it's about one second if you
download web page more than one second
you feel impatient so that's how they
design the technology at the beginning
with 300k per second and that will be
combining voice in the limited amount of
video you can see using your cell phone
or handheld devices and what I've been
working with NTT DoCoMo is on the even
futuristic or future generation on the
fourth-generation
okay in that technology we are trying to
think of a totally different kind of
technology which is not based on the
current cellular system it will be
purely on IP based internet protocol
based technology packet switching okay
because the bandwidth in the wireless
system or the radio spectrum
unlike the optical spectrum you have in
the fiber is very very precious okay
because of the noise in the atmosphere
whereas in the optical fiber we can have
easily therapy per second in the
wireless spectrum and you will be very
difficult to even get megabit per second
okay so a big difference a million times
difference in terms of the efficiency
and there we want to get up to two mega
per second or even ten millisecond in
that case you can even actually view a
high-definition TV on your handheld
device okay that's really to go in the
future and they are even planning
already in 2006 and or seven to roll out
this service okay
and again the third generation is based
on the wideband CDMA and this is using
the third generation technology and some
other issue you have to do with the
convergence with backbone networks okay
if you really want to have very high end
to end performance okay
the wireless spectrum or the wireless
network only
represents as we say the at least last
mile technology okay because fiber will
be built fiber networks will be built
optical networks will build we should
make use of the fiber the enormous
bandwidth available in the wireline
network and use the wireless part as
Davila the last mile connection okay so
just now let me get back to what can be
done currently okay I'm going from the
future generation now back to the
present okay currently you can actually
buy what we call the w AP phone okay
w AP stands for the Wireless Application
protocol from from a carrier which
allows you to actually browse the web
over the existing second generation
technology alright this is the current
world wide web paradigm in the wireline
Network this represents your the desktop
PC okay it's a very simple kind and
server technology okay you send a
request URL you visit a website the
website may run some CGI script and
return a response to your desktop PC
very simple client-server paradigm okay
the wapi the Wireless Application
protocol paradigm is a little bit
different okay now we have a handout
cellular from ok and this is the over
the wireless network what's different is
now you have a w AP gateway that is
owned by the wireless carrier ok in the
middle okay this part is it is like
existing HTTP this is a current internet
protocol but what its difference is now
that you now have to change this is over
the wireless path which they have now to
change the current tcp/ip standard in
order to work over the unreliable and
low bandwidth communication network in
the wireless area so now you have to
have a proxy in the middle ok to forward
your HTTP request to the web server ok
and there's also one distinct function
if that doesn't exist in the current
World Wide Web is that is the push
function ok
currently the your your web
that works in the pool paradigm right
whenever you want to get information
your PC actually pull the information
from a web server but in the WEP network
architecture will actually have a push
paradigm that means the server can
actually push information to your cell
phone okay that creates a lot of issues
even involving economics okay because if
you have a cell phone okay if some of
the advertisement want to push
information to your cell phone who pay
for the airtime cost so all these have
not really been sorted out yet but
that's a big market now in the wireless
internet and people should now try to
rush into the area okay very quickly and
just want to mention quickly that
there's a lot of business opportunities
you can recently see a lot of IPOs of
wireless internet startups because
there's a lot of opportunity the
existing world wide web
built on HTML but if you want to browse
the web using your cell phone you have
to reformat all the web pages into a
different language called Wireless
markup language okay so a lot of these
companies are doing this kind of
conversion okay to help companies to
migrate to the wireless platform okay I
don't want to go into too much detail
now but I just want you concluding the
two more slides that this is a current
PC application okay the the paradigm of
the internet you have a PC connected to
do relatively slow internet up to a few
maybe hundred kilobit per second and
every so often every two years Microsoft
will ask you to upgrade your operating
system so you're paying a lot okay
because you have to keep on upgrading
software to deal with all the new
applications all right and in the future
okay we will have the three inclined
broadband internet model alright and
this is what we call the application
service provider model okay in the sense
that you no longer need to really
upgrade your software maybe everyone
know every two years the upgrading of
the serf software will be done and an
ASP server okay what you really need is
just a Netscape Browser or in the next
web browser what we call think
most of the processing is done at the
server level okay of course besides a PC
I think line PC you may have a PDA a
laptop and a cell phone okay all
connected to this prepend Internet in
the sense this broadband technology
allows us to see the whole internet as a
local area network ok even though this
server is maybe across the nation you
will see that actually almost like in
your local office because of our
broadband internet so that's a shift in
the paradigm and even Microsoft is
seeing this model as a competing to
they're really heavy PC model ok
so we're seeing a lot of changes in the
Internet industry ok now let me conclude
this by actually saying something that
you hear a lot more about this work how
to network physical objects in the
afternoon talks given by Professor Samba
is this is the ultimate vision what we
call in the dream client so instead of
talk about cell phone ok we're now
talking about a barcode ok but of course
not existing barkow
it's a chip that cost me a penny to be
embedded in any pieces of consumer goods
that you can imagine for example a piece
of tie box manufactured by Procter &
Gamble actually our sponsor for this
work so in the future a lot of these
existing barkos we call the uniform
product code UPC Paco will be replaced
by a tag which is electromagnetic Ted
okay that you can sense or read or you
can read without actually scanning them
ok current Barco if you go to the
supermarket you have to check out at the
the long queue in the checkout counter
and if you have to really skin every
piece with a line of sight we have these
new technologies ok you don't have to
scan them or scan them anymore directly
it will be is like if you have a bunch
of objects with your tectus which are
tagged by this low-cost taking
technologies you have a PDA of a cell
phone you can sense everything around
you without actually scanning them ok
and this is happening ok and let me show
you maybe I can show this this is a year
chip you can even see that at the middle
this is a business car given to me by
mode
our sponsor okay at the middle is
something like a two millimeter chip
okay that is going to replace a buckle
all right and right now it costs about
two cents and have one thousand bit in
it okay okay I don't know how you know
how many objects can you tag in 1,000
bit okay with 350 350 bits you can
actually uniquely identify every single
atom in the universe
all right okay so we've got thousand bit
you can really last a long time
I guess all right okay yeah so and this
is very low cost okay every day there
are feed billions of objects being
skinned okay
and now with this tacking the launch you
can imagine there will be trillions of
objects sensed okay maybe in every hour
okay so this is going to create a next
revolution in the Internet
okay the internet will be used not just
to retrieve information but will be used
to actually connect physical objects to
obtain physical information and I guess
you can already see there are a lot of
applications on manufacturing infantry
control supply chain management and
really key impact on the next generation
ecommerce and I don't want to really
talk too much because professor sama
will be talking a lot more about this in
the afternoon and I would like to stop
here and maybe take one question
[Applause]
Thomas Watson who was at the time head
of IBM right he said that he predicted
that in the future there will be only
two or three major computers in the
world right then the eight is the
personal computer became popular so this
statement became the subject of much
ridicule because you know as an example
of how famous people can falter when
they particular feature but now when you
look at the internet it begins to appear
that computers are to heaven our Tech's
are actually applying not so much to
produce anymore
the actual computed computing is
distributed so do you think that
actually all watching was right well as
you say we'll see that now it's my last
slide show right right now a lot of the
computing power if the ASP model is
right we'll be pushing all the computing
power back to a centralized a computer
like because the server is getting more
and more powerful whereas all the
devices they want to wear okay
or maybe distribute around this room
will get less and less computation than
power and maybe they could be a passive
by the way I didn't mention the detector
I show you manufacturing by Motorola
will only two cents is passive no
battery okay so a lot of power actually
get it from the atmosphere all right so
to answer your questions you know I
don't have the crystal boy in front of
me so I cannot tell you the future but I
would have to say that a lot in the
future everything will be distributed
okay and there will be a shift in
paradigm okay continue shipping paradigm
back and forth depends on the advances
in technology
I almost never get consent so I would
like to talk to you about quantum
computers now who here is heard of
Moore's law here has not heard of
Moore's law okay a couple of people if
Moore's law is this law that was
proposed by Moore the chairman of Intel
in the 60s he pointed out that the size
of the components of computers and hence
the power of computers the size of
components was going down by a factor of
two every two years and as a result the
power of computers was going up by a
factor of two every two years okay if
you extrapolate this this means that in
every every ten years all right
we're sorry every 20 years you go bed
down by a factor of a thousand in size
as a popular Trojan pointed out the
current scale on computer chips is point
one micron that means that if we go on
for another 20 or 25 years will actually
have computers that are at the scale of
atoms now it's not clear if we're going
to get there because Moore's law is a
phenomenological law about human
ingenuity it's love not a law of nature
but if we are going to get there we're
going to have to use quantum mechanics
and that's what I'm going to tell you
about okay so who here has heard of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle okay
who here is not her to the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle see it's even more
famous than Moore's law okay
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle is
what how quantum mechanics tells you the
limits on how well you can measure
things and on how fast you can do things
at the quantum scale and the device is
going to describe to you actually
operate at the limits that are given by
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle so
quantum computers are where Moore's law
meets the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle okay I don't think it deserve
that
okay so and the interest I will luckily
I'm using actually archaic technology to
do this so I will actually be able to
cut my talk in half okay now what are
quantum computers by the way I was
thinking when when nomnom to point it
out that during my interview I said I
knew a lot about mechanical engineering
and I was trying to think what he was
talking about then I realized that I
actually did say that I did know a lot
about quantum mechanical engineering in
fact you can think I am in fact a
quantum mechanical engineer because what
I really know about is how to make
things happen at small scales and that's
what I'm going to tell you now how to
make things happen when the systems that
you're trying to make you're trying to
engineer our quantum mechanical what our
quantum computers okay their devices
well their computers all right they
process information they store
information on individual atoms nuclear
spins or photons that is to say at the
quantum scale all right they operate at
the physical limits of speed dissipation
and memory right they operate at the
limits that are determined by the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle all
right and finally they preserve
information sorry they process
information in a way that preserves
quantum coherence what does this mean
well I'll tell you in just a second all
right so one of the main things you've
got to remember about quantum annealer
way has it has ever taken a course in
quantum mechanics all right see I mean
this is this shows you that the physics
based paradigm for engineering really is
a physics based paradigm all right so
now you guys who took and women who took
courses in quantum mechanics know that
quantum mechanics is weird right quantum
mechanics is weird strange stuff happens
and down at that microscopic scale scale
things do not behave in the same way
they do at the macroscopic scale all
right so if I got to tell you some stuff
and it sounds weird right and you don't
quite understand it that's good all
right niels bohr once said anybody who
can contemplate quantum mechanics
without getting dizzy hasn't properly
understood it all right so if you if you
feeling dizzy that's good it doesn't
you're actually understanding it right
it just means that it's good if you're
not feeling dizzy that's bad
so however I can tell you a lot a lot
about all the quantum near this
weirdness you really need to know for
understanding quantum computation in a
nutshell all right on just one
transparency and it goes under the name
of wave particle duality so what quantum
mechanics says is it's stuff that we
normally think of as waves like sound or
light is actually made up of little tiny
particles light is made up of photons
sound us up made up of phonons okay so
if you look at a very very very very
very faint light and you have a detector
a photo detector for detecting light
rather than just giving you a continuous
signal at some point it will start just
giving you a little clicks and each
click as a photon a light particle
hitting that photo detector similarly
stuff that we think of as particles like
atoms or for that matter of basketballs
okay actually corresponds to a wave so
if I like pick this thing up in the air
and throw it up there all right not a
very good particle but it's still this
clip has a quantum mechanical wave
that's associated with it and that means
it particle-like properties like
position for instance are sort of
smeared out when you get down to the
quantum scale because there's a
wave-like nature that's associated say
with the position and momentum of this
clip as it goes flying through the air
okay now one thing you've got to
remember this at cables so that's fine
that doesn't sound so weird except that
it is kind of weird because the
important thing here is that the waves
in quantum mechanics just like ordinary
waves of light or waves of water or
waves of sound they can add up so if
this is an okay wave for a quantum
system all right for this particle and
this is an okay wave quote for a quantum
system well then so is this so it's okay
to have a quantum particle that has a
wave that has support in two places at
once
and a particle that's described by this
is in some weird quantum sense in two
places at once
all right now is this okay but does this
is this weird yes okay
is our people willing provisionally to
accept this even if it's you that's
weird
who doesn't want to accept this
provision way nobody okay good
otherwise that I have to tell you to
leave the room because everything if you
accept this provisionally then actually
everything I'm going to tell you about
quantum computation all right you're
gonna have to accept so there's no you
know at that's why I don't want like two
minutes down the road to have people
backtracking and saying hold it
alright okay good so I'm gonna take five
more minutes and they'll tell you about
it now any computers we store
information on electrons right a
capacitor we store them capacitors
really capacitors like a bucket for
electrons a whole bunch of electrons
over here is a zero a whole bunch of
electrons over here is a one that's how
computers work now let's go down to the
level we're storing information on a
single electron let's say and an atom is
actually a very nice example of a
capacitor right you can put energy in it
excited to an excited state the Elector
the shape of the electron cloud around
the atom changes so let's think of an
atom as electron over here ground state
registers a zero electron over here
excited state registers of one the atom
storing energy when you go from this
when you go from zero to one okay that's
fine we're just gonna call the ground
state zero and we're gonna call the
first excited state one we can do that
that's fine now
the thing is it's okay for an electron
indeed electrons like doing this it's
okay for an electron to be in the ground
and excited state at the same time that
is a quantum bit or a qubit can register
in some weird quantum sense it can
register 0 & 1 at the same time okay
were there any objections to this so far
good people were convinced I that's what
the people were convinced by my saying
that you weren't allowed to object at
this point okay great so what can you do
so a quantum computer is a system that
stores information on quantum bits or
qubits so a quantum bit let's call it 0
right 0 is electron over here 1 is
electron over here 0 plus 1 is the
of the waves as this physical state of
the system you add up the waves that
correspond to zero and one it's some
funny state that registers here in one
the same time now if that's not bad
enough if I take a whole bunch of these
guys all right let's say I take ten at
them but I put each one in this funny
state zero and one at once zero and one
at once zero and one at once etc all
right I ask what's the state of all of
them together well it's a wave with
remember every component is represented
so I've got a wave with 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 1
0 0 0 1 0 1 1 1 1 1 1
I've 1024 which is 2 to the 10th
I have 1024 components and my 10 quantum
bits are in some funny quantum sense
registering all the numbers between 0
and 2 to the N minus 1 0 and 10 23
written in binary form at once ok so
we're at what we're actually doing is on
a small number of quantum bits a small
number of electrons were extras to
registering a very large number of
numbers as Sonny pointed out if I had
350 bits okay
2 to the 350 which is around you know 10
to the 110 is way more than the number
of particles in the universe they're
only like 10 to the 90 particles in the
universe all right so the power of infra
and this of course is why information is
so powerful with a small number of
things you can tag a lot of stuff a lot
more stuff than you'd ever want a tag
and in this case in our quantum bits
we're actually able to do it all at once
so this is kind of funky and what can
you do with this well here's how you do
quantum computation you have a little a
little gate a quantum logic gate which
is something that for instance moves
electrons around I've actually done this
in terms of photons because photons are
very nice things for storing information
on a photon can wiggle this way which
I'll call 0 or it can wiggle this way
which call 1 it's pretty easy to do this
you just take out your Ray Bans right
and you polarize the light so it's
wiggling this way where it's wiggling
this way but they can also wiggle this
way
right and that's the states at zero and
one at the same time and so I can make a
little gizmo and I'll describe very
briefly how you make gizmos like this
and you can do logic you can make the
photons interact with each other or you
can make the electrons interact with
each other
indeed Nature does this for you because
Nature gives you physical interactions
quantum mechanical interactions between
these systems and you can do little
logic gates so here's for example a gate
where the first guy that goes through
stay is the same alright and the next
guy that goes through gets flipped if
the first guy was one it's called a
controlled-not gate because you do a
knot on the second bit controlled on
whether the first one's a one or not and
now you have this funky situation where
if you put zero plus one in the first
bit then well when you've got zero there
but first the second guy does nothing
and when you have one the second guy
flips okay so you can do logic and you
know that doing logic if you look inside
a regular computer it's just got all
these little logic gates and the takes
bits two by two one by one and two by
two makes them interact with each other
and all of a sudden you're playing doom
right okay so you can take the
mathematical way of saying this is that
you can put in some input X and you can
calculate arbitrary functions f of X
arbitrary digital functions well in
quantum computation what you can do is
you can take all these inputs at once
okay
and you can calculate f of X on all
these inputs at once that is something
you cannot do on a classical computer
and that is where the power of quantum
computation comes from okay now have I
have I is this reasonably clear I'm just
remember it started out the world is
quantum mechanical quantum mechanical
things committee two states at once
quantum bits can be in two states at
once that means a quantum computer can
do two things at once more than that it
can do lots and lots and lots of things
at once and that's why you can do more
on a quantum computer than you can do it
can do on a conventional computer does
this make sense all right I'm sorry okay
so how do we build these things and then
I'll stop so really actually now
remember that the popular Tyrolean said
the difference between an engineer and a
physicist is that engineers do things
right so when I became came here and
became a mechanical quantum mechanical
engineer I felt obliged to start doing
stuff all right actually I was already
doing stuff before I came here but it's
been extremely helpful for me to be in
an environment where people are doing
things because engineers know how to do
things so what I've been doing is I've
been building quantum computers I've
also been working on large systems and
complex systems as well but largely what
I've been doing is called building
quantum computers because this is what
the government will give one money to do
these days okay so how can you do it you
can do it by a whole variety of means
you can use nuclear magnetic resonance
it's essentially exactly the same
technology that when you blow your knee
out skiing you know you go and sit in
some big magnet it makes a lot of
clicking sounds all right and it takes
an image of your knee you can modify
that technology very slightly to put a
bunch of molecules inside the magnet zap
them with microwaves and make them
perform these kinds of simple logic
operations that I described with David
quarry here at MIT we now have the
world's records quantum computers there
are about 10 bits they can perform a few
thousand operations ok they're small and
they're slow but they are performing
these operations at the atomic scale
there's one angstrom between the bits
quantum optics is a beautiful way for
doing quantum computation will describe
in a second how you do that quantum dots
are nice ways of doing this a very very
interesting way of performing quantum
computation is to use superconducting
circuits I don't know if if you read
science you may notice that there are
they just announced a result of a group
of which I'm a member in collaboration
with Delft they made superconducting
circuits where you had a whole bunch of
electrons going around this way we'll
call that a zero okay and a whole bunch
of electrons calling going around this
way we'll call that a 1 and you have
this funny quantum state where they're
doing that at the same time now people
have been trying to do this for more
than 30 years create a whole bunch of
electrons growing on this made a whole
bunch of electrons behind
that way at the same time without
success until now right until justice
last year how did that manage to happen
now okay well and actually why am i able
to work on all these kinds of projects
without like just falling apart there is
a reason what I my goal my role in these
projects is not to do the experiments
because you need world-class
experimentalists who really know what
they're doing in that particular field
in order to make this happen my role is
really a designer to design these
quantum systems and the tools that I've
learned from Nam to do this are
axiomatic design all right AXA meiotic
design is what actually allows you to do
this why because at this very small
scale you're very constrained by nature
right it's very you know the atoms are
already there they know you know nature
says they have to behave in a certain
way you cannot design an electron it
just comes that way luckily they're all
identical okay Nature fabricates them to
exact precision however in order to make
these things operate in this very
constrained environment you have to be
very careful about having uncoupled
designs and you could say that my role
in these collaborations is to ensure
that the designs are uncoupled that's
why we're actually being able to do this
and that's why I think we have a hope of
actually making this happen
on a much larger scale okay let me ice
become running out of space here running
out of space and time oh it's time for
lunch so let me just wind this down here
what else can you do I won't tell you
any more about how you do this let me
just talk about a few more applications
that we have here we've just received a
multi-million dollar murray project
together with the electro RLE here in
the RLE here to do quantum communication
that's where you take in quantum
information like stored on photons
remember this way is zero this way is
one polarization move them down an
optical fiber bring them over here and
pick them up on the other side okay
there's lots of problems with this it's
very difficult to do these experiments
in general because quantum systems are
small all right there at the angstrom
scale they're hard to engineer and
they're hard to manipulate and they're
very sensitive you know you sneeze your
atoms get a cold at the quantum level so
how are we going to do this well luckily
I and our collaborators we came
with a design for what we call quantum
Internet okay
this is uh not like the internet that
Sonny was talking about except that it
consists of computers that are connected
together by communication lines in this
case these are quantum computers that
are connected by quantum information
lines all right now well in our case
they're atoms they sit in little optical
cavities we zap them with light we
communicate by these by photons it's
actually very hard to make this happen
but by thinking carefully about what
parts of these design of this design can
be decoupled from the other parts we
actually have a very nice design and we
ought to have little networks ok with a
few links in them in a couple of years
where is this all going ok and here's
the end so we can all go have lunch in a
second currently we have five to ten
quantum bits we can do about a thousand
operations that doesn't sound like a lot
but you have to remember that four years
ago we had no qubits and no operations
all right and in fact then a couple of
you two years ago we had four cubits and
we could do about ten operations so
we've got a kind of inverse Moore's law
going on here all right every couple of
years we managed to double the number of
qubits that we have in the next few
years we're gonna have twenty to thirty
quantum bits about ten thousand
operations we're gonna have a two maybe
three linked quantum internet in which
we can move quantum information around
from one place to another so let's put
this in the perspective of what popular
traversing was talking about this
morning she was a picture of Moore's law
Moore's law essentially says every 25
years the scale size of components in
computers goes down by a factor of a
thousand in 1950 we had vacuum tubes 10
centimeters all right concise in 1975 we
had integrated circuits but the
components were down there at 10 microns
or so or so a hundred microns in size
now we have we're at the scale where we
have feature sizes of a tenth of a
micron the national semiconductor
roadmap actually takes us down to around
tooth
10 which is pretty amazing given that
using the scissors techniques that we
heard about this morning which is quite
remarkable one's able to do that where
are we all right right here we're right
here at the moment okay this is y2k
we're right here at the scale of atoms
10 to the minus 10th one angstrom we're
building small devices right here we're
making them larger and larger and larger
there's a huge huge industry out there
that is building larger devices okay at
the order of 0.1 microns and making them
smaller and smaller and smaller what
we're hoping is that sometime in the
next 10 years ago all right we're going
to be tunneling up from the lost very
very small scale to the large scale
constructing larger and larger devices
and halfway in between we're gonna meet
people like Popkin who are coming down
from the top and building a larger
devices then we break through you hope
to be able to shake hands with each
other and say hey how's it going all
right
so but you look at so let's definitely
just conclude this is how we're going to
if we are going to be able to make
Moore's Law continue to 2025 which is
around when things are supposed to be
the atomic scale this is how we're gonna
have to do it we're gonna have to store
things at the atomic level we're gonna
have to manipulate things using you know
basic ordinary physics to do it and
we're going to have to use careful
design principles such as axiomatic
design in order to get us there so let
me stop there Thanks